[Music]
the following
is a presentation of the st louis chess
club
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borosch
and in this show i'm going to introduce
you to big new personalities
chess streamers and much much more our
first
special guest is a streamer
very very well known for her gambit
one of the biggest chess streamers on
twitch
signed with envy in december and
she had the highest concurrent view
hosting
her show with her sister block champs
i want to introduce alexandra votes
alexandra please it's a pleasure to have
you here
danish thank you so much for having me i
feel like it was just yesterday when i
was visiting st
louis and we were able to hang out
around the club in person but
this interview format will do for now
yeah so i asked just before we started
what's the situation in
austin is it still snowing it's actually
very foggy right now but there was only
snow for one day which to me felt normal
but i saw people outside like
it's snowing i've never seen snow in my
life and
i was really enjoying just people
watching
that kind of reminds me this is just a
return for you
to texas because you were born in texas
am i right yeah i was born in dallas and
i moved when i was four to canada
so it is a return but i don't really
remember anything from the first time
around
so before we get into it i'm very
curious
because you start to mingle a bit more
with
variety streamers are they welcoming to
you as a chess streamer
they might be more welcoming than even
some chess streamers but could say
i'm mostly teasing the chess community
has been very supportive
and so have the variety streamers i i
think it's a very different kind of
discipline where everybody's focused on
making shows entertaining and having fun
so when you meet people who have that
same goal it doesn't really matter what
game background they come from
and i just wanted to segue into block
champs
how that came about minecraft with chess
is that even possible i mean we did our
best to relay the chessboard
into the minecraft world and try to
actually mix combinations of both
but i have to give credit to my sister
andrea because
she was friends with a lot of these
minecraft streamers and learned that
they like to play chess it was actually
her idea to come up with this tournament
so i have to give her 100
credit for just coming up with the
concept and it was very similar to what
had worked well before with
pogchamps where you take a ton of really
fun and entertaining content creators
who don't have as much experience in
chess and you coach them
and this has worked for a lot of other
sports like dancing with the stars so
now we're kind of trying to do it
on twitch and it ended up working way
better than we expected
and who do you think we're more enthused
by the whole event the minecraft
community or the pogchamp community
i know that that's a slippery topic but
i have to ask
well the pogchamps community is usually
whoever is watching the streamers who
are participating in pog champs
um so i would actually argue that block
champs community
is very similar because it's whoever
likes those minecraft streamers
and also has some interest in chess and
that's who who would be willing to watch
yeah i actually remember watching one of
the streams
where they were actually playing among
us a very popular game
online and on twitch and i saw taboo
asking anyone wants to play chess then
some one of the other streamers
responded yes
i think the other streamer was fundy who
was a minecraft streamer
and then five up the biggest a manga
streamer jumped in
snatched fundy away from taboo and poor
tubbo didn't get the chance to play
anybody
danish you have been watching a lot of
twitch streams you're always
lurking in these chats and i love how
much inside knowledge you have here i i
should always be asking you
did you notice anything else different
like a viewer because i know you watched
both of these events
so i've haven't watched the whole event
of block champs but i was
lurking in these among us streams and
lobbies
and it was fascinating to see how much
talk there is in these twitch
communities about chess
like uh randomly five up would talk
about chess
and it was also funny how they were
trying
desperately to get the opportunity to
get chess on their own streams
yeah five up is actually pretty good at
chess i actually played four player
chess with five up in tubo and fundy
the other night and they're so into
chess and they're actually naturally
very good at it
also and i can tell that they've been
working on their tactics but it does
make sense because chess is this game
that
everybody has some experience with and
when you see other people starting to
play it it's a fun thing
to add on to what you already stream
especially if you're already a gamer at
heart
yeah and uh it kind of feels so natural
for uh
five up because chess can be sort of a
detective game itself you're trying to
find the solution from the maze that's
out there
and you never really know what's the
solution yeah god i i like the way
you're phrasing that because
one thing that we think would be cool
would be to create another similar
tournament
like we did for minecraft but for people
who play among us and try to find some
way to incorporate
the among us game into the chess
tournament too so that it's not just
taking people who play this one game and
doing chess but kind of mixing the two a
little more
i actually like the idea of having
instead of solving tasks and among us
solve small puzzles chess puzzles
so doing something like puzzle rush and
seeing who can solve the most
yeah or just uh you know doing quick
puzzle rush sequences
just to do tasks but of course
in fact like even in these detective
novels i've seen
that they would set up like chess
stories
and you would have to solve it in a
detective kind of way
you have been thinking creatively about
this i really like it
one thing that i'm always trying to be
careful when i do is if we create a
stream
if it becomes too complicated people who
come in
because that's how people watch twitch
they tune in and out kind of get lost
with the plot so i'm always trying to
make sure that
they understand what's going on but then
again among us works and it's like a
30-minute plot so i don't see why
something like that wouldn't end up
working
yeah it does sound like an interesting
topic there
but i did want to touch upon block
champs
so you guys signed with team envy
so this was a co-production between you
guys both
as live you and your sister also how did
andrea come up with the idea of
blockchains
she just had a lot of minecraft friends
who also played chess and she thought
it'd be cool to do a tournament with
them
and then we started talking and we
started planning this since almost
october
november um and we had a lot of
different partners who helped us out so
for example
um envy helped us create the minecraft
server and find somebody who could do
that
chess.com helped us produce the show
which was really helpful
our twitch partner helped us get some
twitch home page time um chess.com and
cash up helped put a prize fund for the
event so there were so many different
people
who helped make this come together
including the players who were such good
sports about everything and
i i was so happy that they were willing
to do it and i hope they had a good time
so
it was really things coming together
perfectly to lead to this event in my
head so i'm just reading the chat both
youtube and twitch and i do encourage
everybody if they have any questions
feel free to ask
i just heard and read about um
the among us chess set is on reddit
right now
which you've never heard this chess set
where is this
i do not know herbivorous if you have
that link
feel free to post it yeah that would be
cool to see i
i'd love to look at what it is unless
it's just like pieces
of among us but that would still be cool
i wish that you could upload custom
skins onto chess.com
i agree because there's so many
communities who would love to
make chess their own like wouldn't it be
great to have
valerian chess sets wouldn't it be great
to have
pokemon chess sets there's so many
communities that chess could reach out
to
yeah i totally agree with that and i
think other games that are
have these creative modes like minecraft
where you can build in it or even among
us where people
are creating their own rules and things
like that they let creators
innovate on top of these games and
people always show chess new patch
coming when
it doesn't really have to change the
game but it could make it more
individualized for everybody so that
it's actually keeping up with
you know twitch trends or what people
are into and making it more enjoyable
for everyone
although you know purists might argue
that that's not
doing the game justice but i think most
people are open to it
yeah there was one more thing that i
wanted to ask
about block champs um
so it was a mix of minecraft
and chess and i was very excited to know
so what was the minecraft minecraft part
yeah so
it was mostly a chess tournament because
they were playing the games on chess.com
but what we wanted to do
is create a better audience experience
for their communities in particular
so what we did is um we worked with some
developers to build something that would
take the
live replay on chess.com as soon as
somebody made a move
and we had a minecraft server that
people could come and watch around so
then the move would get played
in the minecraft world and you'd also
see the two minecraft players on both
sides and people could
walk around and kind of observe so that
was cool because you can't really attend
in-person events now so at least you
could attend virtually with your avatar
even if it's just a chess game i see
yeah meanwhile i've got a chess question
from a person called sapper
pepper asking
why do you hate on the king's indian or
at least i assume that's what he means
by
kid well i i think it's the right thing
to do honestly when your friend makes a
bad decision you have to tell them
and i've been playing the king's indian
for 10 years now
and i still don't understand it my
coaches still don't understand it
it's hard to study um i feel like i get
crushed by stronger rated players
so it's a pretty tough tough opening to
understand and it's so counter-intuitive
yeah it is and there's a another
wasn't a question would it be great to
raise
money for tournaments but if i remember
correctly
uh you together with jan shahadi and
uscf
actually fundraised for a tournament
called isolated queens
not long ago yeah um that was a program
that i worked on last year where every
saturday
i basically wanted to try to get more
females into
the chess scene so i took talked to jen
shahadi
and she helped me organize this and
together with
some donors from my chat map real and
nicola in particular we came up with
like a small prize fund and i would play
a different female streamer each
saturday and it was something like 60
of whatever people donated on my stream
i would donate back to us
women's chess so i think we did that i
think we raised like over 10k so it was
a pretty good start
to hopefully getting some things back to
girls and then with the isolated queens
um they both had a prize fund of
something like 2k or so
i even see our moderator on our twitch
twitch chat uh nigeria is saying
i love playing there oh that's that's
really sweet to hear i know
we're i i stopped or organizing and
hosting those events because things have
gotten so busy lately but
um i know jen wants to work on isolated
queens three and if she does all other
play or help commentate or
you know help bring exposure to it i
just need some help on the
organizational part because things have
gotten so busy
so you've been very busy um
how are you getting used to the more of
the variety
people around you and more of the gamer
community
it's intimidating how good some people
are at variety it's a completely
different skill that
my undergrad and chess career did not
prepare me for you know i was not
training to be a content creator
so what i try to do is really look at
people who are entertaining and do a
good job and i try to learn from them
and see
what different kinds of things sticks
because it's one thing to just do chess
and stay in your comfort zone and it's
another to try something that you're not
as experienced or not as good at and
uh realize that it's going to take you a
while to improve so for for me that's
been an intimidating thing and i
sometimes shy away from it but i'm
pushing myself to do as much as i can
but you're a team with your sister so
i mean at least you guys can brainstorm
time and time again
yeah and well one thing that andrea's
really good at is
she she's very energetic so at least
when it's the two of us doing things
um it's kind of entertaining because you
know it's like me and my pet goblin
walking around so
anything can really happen and i think
it's easier when you're up there
yeah one more thing that i wanted to ask
related to isolated queens is
i see some of these new events and great
events like
i am not a gm who which you just
participated in
and the isolated queens wants and i'm
looking and thinking
what about junior events where it could
be a mix
boys and girls together and it could
provide an opportunity to bond
and also kind of provide competition for
both genders
did that come up for you or jennifer
i think there is the junior speed chess
championship and
generally there are a lot of events for
juniors
um and obviously i'm one person so
there's so many events i can do and one
thing that i try to do is i try to give
back to the communities that
i came from and when i was in that
situation i had help as a way of kind of
returning the favor um i do think junior
events are generally a very good idea
but i think
a lot of those already existed on twitch
and the reason that i was focused on
females on twitch is because i know how
much um having role models and seeing
visibly that there's other girls playing
chess encourage girls to play
and i mean girls are one of the smallest
communities in chess right now so i was
trying to basically
see where i could have the most impact
and try to encourage more female
streamers to just show up so that you
know girls watching can be like oh yeah
actually girls girls do play chess and
they can be good
now i mean we're very appreciative of
that as a chess community
because i just looked at the wimbledon
of chess
tata steel i checked the number of
female participants
and you will not imagine how many
females are participating
do tell not one
yep and to be honest with you
this is the tata steel but is it all of
the sections because i know all of the
sections
there's only a section but there's not
a single female player participating and
the only thing that i find upsetting
honestly i find it upsetting
is that there are plenty of junior
prodigies playing
yet not a single wild card
on and four female players but we have
goriachiki now we have
koneru hampi i don't see that we don't
have an opportunity to give the
wildcards to these people i think
there's an
impro like there's room for improvement
there what do you think about that
i think it's a complicated subject
because on one hand
i absolutely would love to give a spot
to one of these talented females and
then on the other hand
would it take away a spot from a
talented junior but
in general yeah it would be nice to have
a wild spot for
having female players at the events
because again it isn't just for the
event itself but it's also for the
visibility of anybody who is watching
and trying to get into the game and
we've already gone from like five
percent females to chess now getting
closer to 15 and something like that
which is amazing
um so it's clear that initiatives like
this are really helping a lot
and i do believe like judith polgar for
example was a big role model for
plenty of the new and upcoming players
and
i guess even for you absolutely i mean
to know that there was a female who
broke the top 10
when you've been listening to
stereotypes about how
females are worse than chess all the
time is just such an important thing to
keep in your head
that i really think did change people's
own perception of what they're able to
achieve as well
so i want to come back a little bit with
your life story as
a streamer so and again i
encourage the youtube and twitch viewers
to ask their questions if they have
any um how did you start streaming why
did you even start streaming
i just really liked chess and talking
while i play chess
i think that's the most basic form i
never had to stream on my own twitch
account it was just really entertaining
i was still in college and i was also
working at the same time so i was really
busy
with things in my day-to-day and i kind
of wanted some kind of
escape that brought me back to my roots
and when i remembered playing chess as a
kid so i found it and i loved it so much
and whenever i would stream
um i would just be completely immersed
in what i was doing and i'd sometimes go
on like bullet grinds for like four six
hours without realizing anyway so might
as well do it and also
not be completely alone at my computer
yeah
actually i had like the same uh thought
process
of course there's a much much more
smaller streamer but i also realized was
told that hey
you've been studying and playing chess
for so long why don't you share it
as well but i did want to ask this
specific question
so the landscape was completely
different when you started who were
streaming who were part of the chess
community at the moment when you
just started your chess and a streaming
career
um it was three big streamers it was
me chess bra and hikaru um there are
also some people who would stream at
weird hours like mark esserman
and the other other couple people who i
don't think they'd like go much over 200
hours
i know that eric rosen would stream
occasionally
but he was much bigger on youtube but
the the chess community was really small
when i started off
and i remember you talked with the other
variety streamers and they were
kind of flabbergasted to see that
wow with these numbers and you still
kept streaming
and they couldn't imagine that they
would do the same thing
so what helped you be so perseverant
yeah i mean i went full-time streaming
when i think i had
between three to four hundred average
viewers uh which for full-time streamers
now kind of sounds ridiculous
but i mean the reason i was able to do
that is because the community was
so supportive and so generous and
there's no way i would have been here
without those individuals who were
supporting not just me but a lot of
other chess streamers kind of like a
grassroots movement
so they helped me be able to create it
into a full-time job
and it was absolutely risky over taking
some kind of more established
job especially with the kind of career
path i was on at the time
um but i really like risks in general
and
you know no risk no reward i was hoping
it would turn out and i always tried to
give myself
goals and i'd say if i don't hit these
goals within the next year that's what
it's going to take for me to have to
give up
and go back but if i'm going to go for
it you know
i have to give it everything no plan b
burn the boats
so somewhat like a calculated risk you
knew that you were taking risks
but you knew that you're going to work
with it yeah
absolutely so okay so some random
questions here
have you ever thought of acting
i don't know if you've seen our
pre-recorded youtube intros but they're
horrendous and we spend hours working on
them because it's easy to be
real and to be alive but when i have to
turn on the camera and say
hello youtube welcome to my channel it
is just
so bad that being said
being an actress was my dream job as a
kid because i think it's so
fascinating to get to experience the
life of other people
and immerse yourself in a completely
different mindset and do that as a
living
for a living that to me has always been
one of like the most fascinating things
about that job so
hey if i was good that would be
interesting but i don't think i'm cut
out for a day
but if they would say hey alexandra we
want you now
to be part of this ocean's 13 movie
you have a little part you're going to
steal
some very expensive property would you
say yes or no
uh i think it depends on what i was
doing at the time i'm generally very
open to trying new things because
even if i fail i think people remember
you in the long term of your career for
what you succeeded at not what you
failed so it would depend on how much i
would have to give up to do something
like that
if it would be a team of thieves you and
andrea
would that make that would that make it
a better deal
well it depends does that mean that i
can't stream for like a year because
we're on set or does that just mean that
i'm spending half of my time filming um
so it's more about what i would have to
sacrifice to do so it would be more like
a cameo
so just a scene oh absolutely a hundred
percent
okay guess i guess you have a movie deal
already
yeah i don't think that's the case but
um
i think if we ever do get a movie deal
it's going to be something that's like
more
real life and not acting per se but we
have been filming a lot of stuff with
envy our team so i am trying to get a
little bit better at that we basically
play our own characters
but it's the first time we're starting
to work on recorded content so it's
actually a skill i would really like to
develop further and
maybe i can take some classes or
something like that because it is not
easy
so as we're heading towards the end part
of this
interview i would like to ask you so
what are the future is there a future in
chess streaming
also who are your current favorite
streamers
doesn't have to be chess streamers it
could be variety or whatever
or what have you so in terms of the
future of chess streaming
is it where do i see chess in terms of
content growth or where do i see my
stream um
both whichever you'd like to talk about
got it well
in terms of our stream i mean we're
gonna keep uh doing a ton of
different chess content it's always
going to range from you know
doing an odds match with dania
neroditsky to
setting up some kind of event where
we're teaching people who are new at
chess or we're bringing a new audience
one thing that we're going to continue
to focus on is trying to
make chess entertaining for the casual
viewer
and i know we still have a lot of uh you
know
work that we still need to put into that
because it's a very new skill but that
is a huge goal of ours and then in terms
of
where chess is gonna be on on twitch um
it comes in waves and right now we're at
a high point of the wave because queen's
gambit happened
um pogchamps three is coming up uh i
know that chess.com just entered the top
200
most visited websites on the alexa
ratings i think that's what it's called
i don't totally remember
but it does feel like we're nearing
nearing the top so i think
if you look in the short term chess is
probably going to go a little bit down
but i do think chess has longevity which
maybe not as many other games do because
obviously it's been around for a really
long time
but there's there's so many unique
things you could do to adapt on top of
the content we're going to have to make
sure that we really keep good content
creators around if we want to do that
because otherwise you could definitely
just go back to the route of being one
of these
sports that is only watched by people
who are really really good at it like
let's say 1800
1700 1600 and above so i hope that
doesn't happen
so you said we should keep the content
interesting
yeah i think we really do have to keep
the content interesting and as a
community we gotta
keep putting one event after another
because with um
the internet and social media you get
viral bumps right and that's great it
gives you viewership but retention
you know it's like a little fart it just
goes downward so we have to keep spiking
it up every now and then so that way
we maintain this growth so what is the
secret what
as a last takeaway what do you think is
the secret to retain the audience that
we've got as the baseline
definitely will grow even if it falls
back
um i think
the most important thing is focusing on
the viewer
experience nothing else matters there's
like small things where you could be
like oh i'm going to get this
one really cool person that nobody in my
community knows and i'm not going to
give them context i'm going to put them
on my stream
it doesn't really matter or sometimes
you get so caught up in your chest
that you forget the audience is there
you're not talking to them about it
or maybe you're lazy like sometimes
when it comes to stream and you haven't
planned anything and you just do random
stuff instead of actually putting in the
work to organizing an
event three months from now or something
like that so i really think it's people
who are
obsessed with creating good content for
chess
because that is very different there's
people who have been obsessed with chess
until now
and that's how you get the prodigies but
to be really good at making chess
popular you have to be obsessed with
chess content which is a very different
thing
i do want to zoom in on chess content
what do you mean which what is the good
chess content what is that
i think it depends i've watched really
entertaining chess content that is just
you know matches with people where
there's a ton of trash talk and it feels
like
um when i'd be watching people play
skittles and for me
i know that's super entertaining but i'm
also you know not the average chess
viewer a little too high rated to be the
average chess viewer
but then what i've noticed for other
people that they like um
it has to be some kind of format where
um it's people who are really
entertaining like the minecrafters and
for example when we did block champs at
some point um george and wilbur were
just talking about
unrelated stuff during the game which
for chess people was like oh but what's
going on like he moved his queen here
doesn't he see it's under attack but
that doesn't matter
what matters is that there's a storyline
around the chest where one person is
losing
and they're trying to get to this goal
together of if he can get checkmated
before he flags and the banter is so fun
that you see people having the social
activity with chess
as uh the the vehicle for collaborating
together
and the entertainment is not just about
the chess move but also what's happening
so i think it has to be a balance
between these two things
and also just a lot of trial and error
some things you might think are going to
be entertaining
maybe they're not some things you think
are not going to be and they are so a
lot of trying things and when you see
that your audience likes something
either by like what people are saying in
chat or what they're they're sending you
in direct messages or
viewership numbers whatever kpis you
want to look at
then try to do trying to do more of that
so
very much of a learning process it's not
it's not an exact science and that's a
tough thing like if i had the answer we
would be way bigger right now so i'm
also trying to figure it out
i mean it's entertainment it's
entertainment business
you're still you're creating content you
want to
produce something original but then the
viewer decides
exactly and you also have people who do
super serious chess and are super
entertaining like hikaru
who's like the best in the world and
depending on who you are
you have to decide what kind of content
fits your strengths
i i could never do puzzle rush like
we we all have our own strengths yeah
exactly
so yeah
one of my chat viewers asked you didn't
answer your favorite streamers at the
moment so i will have to ask that again
my favorite streamers at the moment i
mean now i've been watching a ton of
minecrafters
and i think the minecrafters are so
entertaining
um for example tubbo because he's live
right now and he's also playing in uh
pogchamps he's very very funny very
energized very high spirited um and it's
really entertaining to watch because i
do like energetic streamers
the other streamer who i look up to a
lot is ludwig because he plans his
content in such a smart way
so i always try to look up to people who
i think i can learn things from and and
what he does
is that he you know records his youtube
videos while using twitch and instead of
just coming and being i'm just going to
do anything today
everything is planned and it's planned
with like a bigger goal in mind too of
like okay now how can i produce this to
youtube content
and that's something that i haven't been
as good at so i always try to look at
people who are good at things that i'm
not and to be like taking notes you know
yeah i guess the secret is to always
keep on improving
yeah exactly what about you who are your
favorite streamers my favorite streamers
so i'm a bit partial i have been
enjoying the vibes of your friend nemo's
twitch streams because anytime i visit
her
stream it's like there's a good vibe
here it's like
awesome like you just go into the place
and say hmm
good jazz music good people why wouldn't
i stay
oh that's so wholesome i love it danish
um other people somebody clip it and
send it to nemo
oh no i'm in trouble now no no i think
she'll love it
um yeah so otherwise five up
i really love the way he solves and
cracks
among us cases and he's been
one of my go-to's loved
watching him and listening him listening
to him and he's also a very good talker
and a fun
guy to listen to so those are my
favorites
i mean those are two great streamers and
i think people cycle through
who they tend to watch all right
again alexandra thank you for so much
for taking your time
and uh coming by to this show
and answering some of our questions
likewise danish thank you so much for
having me and i'm looking forward to the
next time i'm able to visit st
louis because it's always so much fun i
just love the chess
center over there yeah thank you so much
and
hope to see you next time as well sounds
good bye
bye bye so thank you so much everyone
for watching hope you had an enjoyable
time you
learned how to do and how to become a
successful streamer
and a great personality thank you so
much for watching bye bye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club